- Every Friday, we will be doing something
we're calling The Weekender!
(cheers)
So, this is just a little, helpful guide,
we put together, as a part of Drew's News,
where we share our picks on what to watch,
read, follow, do and listen
to, over the weekend.
So, welcome to our first
of many Weekenders.
All right, hoo, ha cha cha.
Okay, first, you have to watch the new
Paris Hilton YouTube doc, "This Is Paris."
I was glued to my screen.
Here's a look.
- I just created this
brand and this persona
and this character,
and I've been stuck with her ever since.
(pop music)
- [Interviewer] Is that enough?"
(sighs)
- No (scoffs).
- I mean, I would have watched
this, on mere curiosity,
but what I ended up getting
out of it was much more
than I expected.
So, Paris will actually be
here, on the show, on Monday.
And we're definitely gonna
talk about all of this
and ask her a lot of
questions, I have so many.
Okay, next up, I couldn't
put this book down.
Yeah, I'm reading it, right now!
And you can too!
It's called "Untamed" by Glennon Doyle.
It's a cross between a
memoir and a call to action
that is so inspirational,
it will make you look at how
you're living your own life
in a totally different way.
People are freaking out over this book.
There are all sorts of glowing
reviews on the book, itself.
And here's one of my very favorite.
Robert says, "Would buy
again, very interesting.
Don't let your life get ahold of it."
You'll know why, if you read it.
I love it.
Moving on.
You've gotta check out this podcast,
it's called 365 days with mxmtoon.
Everyday, for the next
year, the 20 year old
sing-songwriter, who created this podcast,
spotlights weird history
and pop culture events
that happened on the same day of the year,
but in another year.
This weekend, she's got
an episode on emojis
and Simon & Garfunkel.
And another on Billie Jean King
and The Beatles breaking up.
She's cool, she's curious
and I totally dig it.
I know.
Next, click that follow button,
for the Young Emperors, on Instagram.
They're a French influencer
couple, who take photography
and make it fashion!
And they take fashion and
make it performance art
and they always match,
in perfect coordination.
Which is a way they say they show
their love for one another.
Look at these outfits.
I know, it's so romantic.
I love them.
And we actually have a
little, blossoming friendship
on Instagram.
So, I would love to say, Young Emperors,
will you please come on the show?
(audience cheers)
Okay, this next one is
a little secret of mine
and a true treat, for your taste buds.
Okay, one day, years ago,
I was at this restaurant
and I had this amazing
cheesecake, big cheesecake fan,
and so, I freaked out and I
was begging them to please
tell me the recipe or
where did they get it.
And they were like, "I don't
know, I think we bought it."
So, I was like, "listen, anything, info,
APP, on this cheesecake.
Because I can't imagine the
rest of my life without it."
So, finally, they gave it up and told me
that I could get one, too.
And now, you can as well,
because it's from Sam's Club.
(audience cheers)
Look at this beauty.
By the way, fun fact, I
haven't actually had it,
since that day, and I've
been dreaming about it,
so, here we go.
I wanna see if it's as good as I remember.
Ratio, creamy, graham like, perfection.
(laughs)
(eating sounds)
I'm sorry, am I wasting
everybody's time, here?
Because I can't, I mean, please.
Okay, I'm gonna stop.
Okay, after the commercial
break, Sam's Club, I love you.
And finally, if you want to
do something this weekend,
shopping without having
to leave the house,
check out the website, ruelala.com.
They've got the best of
designer clothing, accessories,
home, beauty, everything, at
such good freaking prices.
And guess what?
We're teaming up with them.
And we're launching Drew La La.
(audience cheers)
That's right, every
Tuesday, starting next week,
we'll be sharing our
favorite products with you.
And we're gonna have some sweet deals.
To get everyone pumped up about it,
today's VFFs, virtual friends and family,
you're each getting a
$50 credit, to Rue La La.
(audience cheers)
Yeah, that's the way
to go into the weekend!
And that is The Weekender!
(upbeat music)